well let's bring in our political
correspondent Rob Powell who's here and
you've actually come armed with a bit of
breaking news haven't you rob yeah Lord
Goldsmith Zach Goldsmith has decided to
resign he was a minister
um for the environment he's tweeted his
um resignation letter in the last 10
minutes
um or so it's a very lengthy letter two
full A4 pages with lots of stinging
criticism that as he sees it about the
government's record on the environment
he says that the government has been
stepping back in terms of Animal Welfare
ditching a bill related to that but also
more worryingly he says the UK has
visibly stepped off the world stage and
withdrawn its leadership on climate
change and nature uh stinging criticism
for the Prime Minister Rishi sunak as
well saying that he used to be able to
Zach Goldsmith saying he used to be able
to get so much done as a minister but
now struggles to essentially get the
Prime Minister interested accusing him
of being uninterested and saying that
that signal or lack of signal lack of
interest in the environment and climate
change from number 10 is trickling down
through through Whitehall the other
thing to mention though whilst there's
no mention of it in this lengthy
resignation letter Lord Goldsmith in the
last 24 hours had also been in the news
because he faced criticism by the
Privileges committee over how he had
described an investigation into Boris
Johnson and what he said to the commons
over lockdown parties he was essentially
criticized by that Committee of MPS for
as they saw it undermining the committee
and undermining the process of
parliament so this is someone who is
very close to Boris Johnson an ally of
Boris Johnson so whilst this resignation
ostensibly is about the environment
the timing is interesting coming as it
does at this point so I don't think you
can see it without that context of the
route he's been in with the current
Administration over the former prime
minister Boris Johnson